[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
die zahl der positiv getesteten
mitarbeiter beim fleischfabrikanten
tönnies ist inzwischen auf über 1000
gestiegen
das dürfte doch nicht die letzte zahl
sein die aus gütersloh vermeldet wird
ministerpräsident laschet spricht vom
größten bisher nie dagewesenen
infektionsgeschehen in nordrhein
westfalen
eines ist aber auch klar selbst wenn das
virus in diesem fall mit einem oder gar
mehreren arbeitern aus osteuropa
eingereist sein sollte wie laschet es
diese woche formulierte massenhaft
verbreitet hat es sich nicht irgendwo im
ausland sondern bei turniers in
westfalen von dort berichtet heiko
raulin westfalen am abend mit bauzäunen
werden wohnhäuser und straßenzüge
abgeriegelt hier wohnen vor allem
menschen aus osteuropa die im tennis
werk arbeiten jetzt sind sie in
quarantäne festgesetzt
unser einsatz auftrag von der stadt war
oder ist im laufe des tages noch heute
die leute zu versorgen da werden wir
lebensmittel zusammen packen die wir
besorgt haben
für zirka zwei tage also bis das
wochenende überstanden ist ein
turbulenter tag los ging es mit einer
pressekonferenz des kreises gütersloh
der leiter des krisenstabs ist sauer auf
tunis da das unternehmen keine
vollständigen personal listen an die
behörden übermittelt habe kommen nur
dann an die menschen dran wenn wir
wissen wo sie wohnen und deswegen sind
wir gestern späten abend mit dem
arbeitsschutz bei der firma tönnies
gewesen nachdem wir ordnungsverfügung
nachdem es sozusagen mit gutem zureden
nicht geklappt hat ordnungsverfügung
erlassen haben das uns tatsächlich
komplett alle personal listen an der
stelle vorgelegt werden
über 1300 adressen im kreis gütersloh
müssen die behörden nun abfahren um die
quarantäne zu kontrollieren und die
bewohner weiter aufzuklären über 7000
menschen müssen zu hause bleiben
das verhältnis zwischen kreis und
konzern ist mehr als angespannt
also ich will erst mal sagen das
vertrauen dass wir in die familie
wittmann junior setzen ist er auf null
das muss ich so klar sagen eine
botschaft die bei turniers wohl an kam
noch eine pressekonferenz nur wenig
später der firmenchef clemens tönnies ja
auch unter quarantäne steht geht
überraschend persönlich vor die kameras
er entschuldigt sich und verweist bei
der zusammenarbeit mit dem kreis auf
probleme mit dem datenschutz wir haben
datenschutzrechtliche probleme
eigentlich dürfen wir diese adressen
nicht haben das ist wird der datenschutz
und auch das werk die werkvertrags das
werkvertragsrecht gibt uns eigentlich
nicht das recht diese daten
beziehungsweise die wohnadressen zu
haben denn jetzt steht massiv unter
druck
rücktrittsforderungen werden laut er
signalisiert ein umdenken
wir werden diese branche verändern das
steht fest
das ist auch nicht nur eine eine
erkenntnis dieser dieser pandemie
sondern auch eine eine erkenntnis die
schon länger habe
die behörden versuchen an den lockdown
für den kreis gütersloh zu verhindern
ob es auch gelingt ist noch unklar der
fall turniers zeigt einmal mehr wie hoch
ansteckend dieses virus ist wie rasant
es sich ausbreiten kann
wenn sich viele menschen miteinander in
geschlossenen räumen aufhalten
diese erfahrung hatten zuvor ja schon
viele andere gemacht unter anderem auf
kreuzfahrtschiffen die zu schwimmenden
quarantäne station wurden zu albtraum
schiffen die jetzt doch alles still
stehen die gesamte kreuzfahrtbranche ist
in der pandemie praktisch zum erliegen
gekommen
das ist nicht nur für die reedereien
wirtschaftlich hart es wirkt sich auch
auf die schiffbauer aus gerade auf die
führenden deutschen kreuzfahrt werften
im niedersächsischen papenburg und in
mecklenburg vorpommern eine stadt
berichtet
so soll er einmal aussehen der
ozeanriese aus mecklenburg vorpommern
im vergangenen november schleppte die
werft das mittelschiff von rostock nach
wismar
dort sollten der global green bug und
heck angeschweißt werden
doch die werft steht corona bedingt
still knapp 3000 mitarbeiter sind in
kurzarbeit durch die pandemie droht die
pleite
auch den vielen zulieferern wie klaus
[ __ ] lampen und seinem ships kabel
logistikzentrum
wir haben natürlich hier viel material
liegen
und das kostet liquidität und wir müssen
die liquidität stemmen und das können
wir auch im moment noch fertig
zugeschnittene chips kabel im wert von
sechseinhalb millionen euro wo lampen
hofft dass die werft bezahlt dazu muss
deren malaysischer eigentümer eine von
politik und banken gesicherte notreserve
anzapfen
die landesregierung hat grünes licht
gegeben die box sind 260 millionen euro
drin und davon 105 millionen euro
freigegeben werden und dazu brauchen wir
noch die zustimmung von 17 banken nicht
nur die schiffbauindustrie ist durch die
korona krise in schieflage geraten
der ganze kreuzfahrttourismus erlebt
eine flaute urlaub auf den schwimmenden
kleinstädten kann sich derzeit kaum
jemand vorstellen zu gefährlich zu viele
menschen die bleiben zu hause
mich würde stören werden was auftritt
und allen quarantäne müssen oder witzen
und irgendwo fest das kann ich nicht
brauchen
weltweit müssen etwa 400
kreuzfahrtschiff in den häfen bleiben
darunter die aida flotte mit 14 schiffen
auch deren rostocker reederei braucht
eine kurzfristige finanzspritze geht es
wahrscheinlich so um 500 millionen euro
um also auch diese krise im bereich der
kreuzfahrt zu überstehen wie lange diese
krise noch anhält ist völlig offen ihre
auswirkungen können noch jahre zu spüren
sein sagen branchenkenner
wenn wir heute mit den kunden reden und
die kunden sagen uns also neue
schlüsselstellungen die könnt ihr jetzt
erst mal die nächsten zwei drei jahre
mindestens vergessen ja dann wissen wir
dass wir auf einen auftrags loch zu
steuern
das bereitet auch zulieferer klaus [ __ ]
lampen sorgen seit jahrzehnten ist er in
der branche für ihn müssen die
schiffbauer umdenken
man muss vielleicht auch etwas ändern in
den neuen schiffen dass man vielleicht
auch eben epidemien besser erkennen kann
auch an bord das man besser eine
isolierstation hat vielleicht sind das
alles dinge und auflagen die für den
kreuzfahrttourismus kommen werden egal
wie in mecklenburg vorpommern will die
schiffbauindustrie an ihrem kreuzfahrt
giganten festhalten
nicht nur in der korona
krisenberichterstattung machen ja große
unternehmen große schlagzeilen die
werften die lufthansa oder aktuell die
misere bei karstadt kaufhof
auch wenn die schon lange vor corona
begangen wenn viele arbeitsplätze auf
einen schlag wegfallen schaut die ganze
republik hin wenn kleine sterben ist das
hingegen ein leiser tod wird zum
beispiel ein kleines souvenir shop hat
geht durch corona auch in die knie ohne
touristen keine kunden
und dann kann man irgendwann auch keine
gewerbemieten mehr zahlen sylvia
bleßmann zeigt wie sich das in berlin
auswirkt in berlins historischer mitte
ist es still geworden sonst gegen krisen
ihm nun herrscht in den touristischen
ecken der stadt flaute gegen die
plötzlichen und nie dagewesenen
ladenschließungen war kaum ein
gewerbemieter resistent weiß die chefin
des städtischen wohnungsbauunternehmens
dass ihr 800 wohnungs und 150
gewerbemieter hat es ist tatsächlich so
dass die wohnungsmieter nicht so nicht
viele anträge auf stundungen gestellt
haben es dann wirklich die
gewerbetreibenden die uns sorgen machen
und mit denen muss sie reden denn für
drei monate wurden stefan pelz die
mietzahlungen bereits gestundet noch
immer kommen kaum kunden erst ratlos wie
es weitergeht hofft auf verständnis
seiner vermieterin manche kosten konnten
reduzieren aber die mieter ist halt da
auch wenn der umsatz nicht da ist die
miete ist halt da nun 70 prozent unserer
gewerbemieter sind
von dieser krise aktuell betroffen für
uns als unternehmen bedeutet das
natürlich auch die signifikante einbußen
dennoch ist kündigung für sie keine
lösung im historischen nicolai foto wird
nun über mietminderung und mit verzicht
nachgedacht denn touristen kommen nicht
und berliner die ihr langlaufen die
kaufen nichts den langen stillstand hat
auch jan schröder schlecht verkraftet
alle staatlichen hilfen sind verbraucht
einnahmen hat kaum wir sind wir
vielleicht bei zehn prozent des normalen
umsatzes und sie warten einfach auch
leute aber es sind keine da das ist
jetzt die ruhe vorm sturm
also ich sehe ist ein bisschen pessimist
durch das da noch ganz viele auf der
strecke bleiben werden weil einfach das
geld nicht kommt in berlin haben nur 0,2
prozent der wohnungsmieter nicht gezahlt
den trend bestätigen vermieter
deutschlandweit alle sorgen sich ums
gewerbe also insbesondere im
gewerblichen vermietung bereich gibt es
probleme auf seiten der vermieter
mittelfristig ist hier auch nicht
absehbar wie groß der schaden wird er
weiß nur jetzt schon deutlich darauf hin
dass hier eine große problem welle auf
uns zurollen wird auf einer mieter demo
in berlin wurde heute bereits vor der
räumungs und verdrängungs welle gewarnt
die im herbst kommen könnte wenn mieter
ihre schulden nicht bezahlen können und
ausländische fonds verstärkt zugreifen
das problem für uns ist nicht der
bewohner sondern dass wir aus unserem
gewerbe me thron verdrängt werden einen
mieten deckel für gewerbetreibende
fordert der mann der auf die demo ging
weil seine kids buchhandlung in
kreuzberg gerade eine kündigung bekommen
hat den laden gibt es seit 20 jahren in
dem haus das nun ein investmentfond
gekauft hat viele haben sorge dass hier
raus müssen der architekten der vierten
etage statt 13 9 36 euro für den büro
quadratmeter zahlen
ich dachte seinen druckfehler also ich
konnte es nicht glauben weil die zahl
ebenso exorbitant ist und das verändert
natürlich das ganze viertel dramatisch
weil natürlich viele auch
kleingewerbetreibende nicht mehr
mitkommen dass die vier kreuzberg
typische kreativszene weichen soll
wollen sie nicht hinnehmen in ihrem kiez
und jetzt nachrichten geht es erstmal
noch mit dem krone thema weiter heißt ja
in vielen teilen der welt breitet sich
das krone virus weiter rasant aus zu den
besonders betroffenen ländern zählt
brasilien
dort sind
allein gestern fast 55.000 neue
ansteckungen registriert worden
und damit steigt die gesamtzahl der
erfassten infizierten auf mehr als eine
million
die tatsächlichen zahlen dürften noch
weit höher liegen auch bei brasilien
vergleichsweise wenig testet mitten im
parteiinternen streit über den rauswurf
des brandenburgischen landeschefs
kalbitz kam die afg heute zu einem
bundeskonvent im sächsischen lohmen
zusammen
bundeschef leuten steht unter anderem
wegen des vorgehens gegen kalbitz seit
einiger zeit parteiintern in der kritik
ein antrag auf dem bundeskonvent hatte
morton unverantwortliche spaltung
versuche vorgeworfen und konsequenzen
gefordert
er wurde von den delegierten
mehrheitlich abgelehnt heute ist
weltflüchtlingstag vor knapp 20 jahren
von den vereinten nationen ins leben
gerufen wird damit jährlich am 20 juni
auf das schicksal der flüchtlinge
aufmerksam gemacht politiker
hilfsorganisationen und experten riefen
gerade auch mit blick auf die korona
krise zum schutz dieser menschen auf
nach un-angaben waren ende des
vergangenen jahres fast 80 millionen
menschen auf der flucht
gut sieben wochen vor der
präsidentenwahl in belarus jemals
weißrussland hat es bei
regierungskritischen protesten gestern
abend offenbar dutzende festnahmen
gegeben
in minsk versammelten sich hunderte um
unterschriften für die kandidatur von
oppositionspolitikern abzugeben
präsident lukaschenko geht seit wochen
hart gegen andersdenkende und politische
gegner vor am donnerstag hatte er seinen
aussichtsreichsten herausforderer victor
barcot festnehmen lassen
ein us gericht hat entschieden dass das
brisante buch des ehemaligen
präsidentenberater john boten erscheinen
darf donald trump hatte das verhindern
wollen
allerdings sind die markantesten
passagen inzwischen ja eh schon
öffentlich mit enthüllungen durch
ehemalige mitarbeiter hat trump
inzwischen auch einige erfahrung
anders übrigens als andere präsidenten
die aber ja auch nicht ständig ihre
leute feuer
jedenfalls weiß trump auch was das beste
gegenmittel gegen öffentliche aufregung
ist durch andere erregern ablenken zb
einer wahlkampf massenveranstaltung
mitten in corona zeiten ausgerechnet an
dem wochenende an dem vor allem schwarze
amerikaner dem ende der sklaverei vor
155 jahren gedenken und ausgerechnet in
12 oklahoma ein native sind berichtet
china bak im gebet ihr protest gegen den
präsidenten der sicherheitsmann bei
trumps wahlkampf kundgebung findet das
nicht gut
also wird china weil sie nicht
freiwillig gehen will festgenommen von
der polizei sie sagt sie hätte ein
ticket sowie fast 20.000 andere aber die
sind alle trump fans da um ihrem idol
zuzüge jeden tag opfert er sich für uns
für jeden von uns egal wer wir sind ob
schwarz weiß asiatisch gelb es ist ihm
egal
[Musik]
sie halten trump für den allergrößten
aber viele im land werfen dem
präsidenten vor die menschen zu
polarisieren
ausgerechnet hier in teils wahlkampf zu
machen wo anfang juni 1921 ein weißer
mob zum schwarzen viertel zog rund 300
menschen wurden ermordet der schlimmste
rassistische exzess der us geschichte
die symbole dieses rassismus stürzten
demonstranten letzten acht mancher orts
vom sockel
die statue eines südstaaten generals in
motion eine ausnahme fast alle proteste
verliefen friedlich
an diesem sonntag dem 19 juni an dem das
ende der sklaverei in den usa gefeiert
wird aber das versprechen von gleichheit
hat sich für viele schwarzen amerika
immer noch nicht erfüllt
es hat ein paar jahre in berlin gelebt
sie wirft tram provokation vor weil er
seine kundgebung zunächst genau auf
diesen june teams gelegt hatte wir sind
nur hier und hoffen etwas zu verändern
dass trump angeht jeder böse mensch hat
auch seinen nutzen seine intoleranz und
seine rhetorik ich weiß nicht wie man es
noch nennen sollte aber trump ist damit
so etwas wie ein katalysator für all das
hier motivation für den gemeinsamen
protest und die entschlossenheit
friedlich veränderungen herbeizuführen
aber der präsident wirft nun per tweet
alle demonstranten in einen topf mit
anarchisten plünderern abschauen wie er
schreibt krams wahlkampfteam verbreitete
dieses video cnn habe berichtet dass ein
kleiner schwarzer junge vor einem weißen
rassisten kleinkind wegrennen ein fake
das original sieht so aus trumps helfer
posteten auch ein rotes dreieck in den
konzentrationslagern der nazis das
abzeichen für kommunisten facebook
sperrte den post heute abend könnte der
präsident hier weiter öl ins feuer
gießen viele erwarten genau das von ihm
und nehmen dafür in kauf dass sie sich
anstecken mit dem corona virus und jetzt
nochmal 15 mit den lottozahlen dieses
samstag sie lauten wie immer ohne gewähr
1 27 11 14 40 superzahl 3 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 6
und jetzt die wetteraussichten morgen
überwiegen im osten und südosten die
wolken und es kann einzelne schauer
geben sonst scheint häufig die sonne und
es bleibt meist trocken
die temperatur steigt auf werte von 19
bis 26 grad
am montag gibt es vor allem im süden
noch etwas regen ab dienstag scheint die
sonne dann von einem
wolkenlosen himmel es wird deutlich
wärmer am mittwoch bis 31 grad
das war es von uns die kollegen vom
aktuellen sportstudio freuen sich wenn
sie dran bleiben und danach so gegen
0.25 gibt es die letzte hot express hat
uns morgen wieder auf wiedersehen
[Musik]